نشره وزاره الثقافه السعوديه تقريرا تضمنا
نتائج دراسه تحليليه اجرتها على جيل ما
بعد الالفيه رمزت اليهم بالجيل زد للكشف
عن تفضيلاته للفعاليات والانشطه الثقافيه
في البلاد من ابرز نتائج هذه الدراسه ان
78% من جيل ما بعد الالفيه في السعوديه
متحمسون للتجارب الثقافيه خصوصا سكان
المناطق الشماليه مشيره في الوقت ذاته الى
ان التكاليف المرتفعه تعد اهم المعوقات
التي تحول دون حضورهم لهذه الفعليه
تفاصيل اكتر حول ثقافه جيل ما بعد الالفيه
في السعوديه نستعرضها مع زميل سالم
الراجحي
الكثير من التساؤلات تدور حول الجيل
الجديد او جيل بعد الالفيه عن اهتماماتهم
وطرق تفكيرهم وعن مستقبلهم ايضا
ويمثل هذا الجيل نحو 99% من اجمالي عدد
سكان السعوديه وفقا لاخر البيانات الرسميه
وزاره الثقافه السعوديه نشرت دراسه حول
نظره جيل ما بعد الالفيه للانشطه
والفعاليات الثقافيه
ثمانيه وسبعون في المئه من جيل ما بعد
الالفيه في السعوديه
متحمسون للتجارب الثقافيه وخصوصا سكان
شمال البلاد وفقا للدراسه
التكاليف المرتفعه والاوقات غير المناسبه
اكبر العقبات التي تمنع جيل ما بعد
الالفيه من حضور الفعاليات الثقافيه التي
تنظم في مختلف مناطق السعوديه تعديل
المزاج والسعي نحو اشباع الشغف من اكثر
الدوافع التي تحدد مفهوم الهوايه لدى جيل
ما بعد الالفيه وكيف يقضون اوقاتهم
السينما ومشاهده الافلام اكثر الانشطه
الترفيهيه رواجن ورغبه دجيل ما بعد
الالفيه او ما يسمى بالجيل زد وهذا يجعل
الفرصه مواتيه لصناع الافلام ودور السينما
لاستغلال هذه الرغبه في صنع المزيد من
الاعمال
وتوصلت الدراسه التي اجرتها وزاره الثقافه
السعوديه الى زياده الوعي الى دجيل ما بعد
الالفيه لنعارض الكتب وفعاليات الفنون
البصريه مثل فعاليات نور الرياض
الصور افضل وسيله للتواصل مع جيل ما بعد
الالفيه حيث اظهرت الدراسه ان هذا الجيل
يفضل التواصل البصري والفعاليات في
الاماكن المفتوحه
في جامعه الملك سعود الدكتور عبد السلام
الوائل حياك الله الدكتور
اول شركه بتقرا هذه النتائج الدراسه
من ناحيه حجم العينه على هذا الكبير 5,000
وشويه وغطت يعني اجيال مختلفه همم النتائج
يعني يمكن اكثر شيء في النتائج انه في
اختلاف ما بين الذكور والاناث في ما هو
المنشطه الثقافي ان الذكور يركزون على
البعد عن الثقافه
بينما بالنسبه
للاناث هي اكثر شيء اسلوب حياه همم الطبخ
مثلا والازياء والحكاوي فهذا الفارق كان
ملفه الحقيقي
واضح انه
مثلا المتكرره انه في دائما اختلاف ما بين
الجنسين في كل مكان بالعالم في كل تقاوم
العالم في رؤيه الامور وانعكست او ان وجدت
فيها هذا المجال وبالنسبه لاقبال هذا
الجيل على المناشد الثقافيه يعني الكلام
عن
الفنون البصريه السينما وغيرها ايضا
الموسيقى فكيف شايفه ايضا بالنسبه بناء
على هذه الدراسات
الواقع عندنا هنا في نهايه الاقبال على
المناشطه الثقافيه
والمقررات المرجعيه اللي هي الدول الاخرى
همم في في المسرح ركز بالذات على قضيه
المسلحه والفنون البصريه
والموسيقيه والمتاح في يبدو انه هذه 100
خاصه بهذا الجيل يبدو انه هذه يعني خصيصه
ثقافيه وهنا وقت على ما
يكون في قبال على قضيه الذات المتاحف تقصد
انه ما في فرق بين هذه الاجيال في مساله
الاقبال على المتاهه بتحديدا هذا ما زعموه
المتاحف في مقابل اعداد الاخرين والجنسيات
الاخرى تحدث عن المتاحف في دول متقدمه على
سبيل المثال هذه موجوده صحيح
ما كان في خليجيه بشكل عام لكن مقابل
التجاريه في نفس المدينه خلقه تمثيلهم
كبير
يجتذب مو بجزء من ممارسه بالمقابل الاقبال
على المهرجانات كبير والتقرير شاف انه
الاجيال الاقدام بالذات ال- ال-
الاقدم واحد من هذا الستينات يحب
المهرجانات بشكل اكبر ههه ايضا
ايضا في همم نتيجه لففتتني الحقيقه
بالموضوع حلو اللي هو انه الثلاثه جيال
اكس واي زي كلهم يحبونه الثقافيه بس
التقرير راى ان الجيل ما بعد الالفيه
الجيل الزد اكثر نشاط من الاجيال الاخرى
في الاقبال على هذه النشاطات وفي المشاركه
فيها كمان تطوعين
78 متحمسون للتجارب الثقافي من العيينه
وخصوصا سكان شمال البلاد في دلالها هذا
الامر له سكان شمال البلاد تحديدا يخصهم
هذا التقرير من هذه النسبه بان لديهم حماس
بالفعل ل- اا لقبال على المنشط الدقهليه
يمكن
المنطقه الشماليه من المملكه عدد السكان
في كبير جدا
فبالتالي اي اختلاف
بالاجابات
تؤثر يعني ترفع الاجابه نعم ولا لا فهذه
لها دور كبير جدا بصراحه لم اطلع على حجم
العينه في قضيه شمال البلد لكن اعرف من
خبره من خلال العمل في مركز الوطني العام
انه لما تكون المنطقه همم مليانه بالسكان
اي نتيجه تكون حساسه التكاليف المرتفع
الاوقات غير المناسبه هي اكثر العقبات
التي تمنعها هؤلاء عن حضور الفعاليات
الثقافيه في مختلف هل تتفق مع هذا هذه
النتيجه بانه هي الاسباب الرئيسيه
عامه يعني موجوده بشكل عام عند همم جنس
معين عند الثلاثه ولا يبعد منطقه معينه في
همم
الحاحه او تكرار من مختلف الفئات على ان
ال ال السعر وعلى ان التوقيت هذول اكبر
عائقين ويمكن انه كذلك الفعاليات ما هي
موجوده في كل المناطق المملكه
على مناطق المملكه بشكل متساوي مثلا او او
متساوي لكن انها مركزه في مناطق اكثر من
غيرها طيب
ايضا الارقام حول استخدامات جيل ما بعد
دلال وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي ايضا مع
الزمان
منذ ما يزيد عن 12 عاما بدات وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي رحلتها في هذا العالم
واصبحت الادوات الاساسيه التي تحدد يوم
الانسان كيف يقضيه وعلى اي منصه الواتساب
اكثر التطبيقات شيوعا واستخداما لدجيل ما
بعد الالفيه بسبعه وثمانون في المئه يليه
سناب شات بنسبه ثمانيه وسبعين في المئه في
مجال تطبيق ثالثا كما نشاهد في هذا رسم
البياني باربعه 74% وفقا للدراسه التي
اجرتها وزاره الثقافه السعوديه ما هي
استخدامات جيل ما بعد الالفيه لوسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي
الحصول على المعلومات وشراء السلع اضافه
الى الخدمات وتحميل البرامج والالعاب ابرز
الاستخدامات التي ينفذها جيل ما بعد
الالفيه عبر وسائل التواصل
ويقضي هذا الجيل سبع ساعات يوميا كمعدل
متوسط لممارسه الانشطه عبر الانترنت منها
خمس ساعات لوسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
واتساب وسناب شات والانستغرام اهم ثلاث
وسائل لاستهداف جيل ما بعد الالفيه
بالاعلانات بشرط ان تكون جذابه ومبتكره
شايف شلون زمان تغيرت دكتور عبد السلام
زمان كانت الكتب
المخطوطات وغيرها من الامور الموسيقى
شرائط هي اللي تشكل ثقافه الانسان اليوم
اصبحت واتساب 78 و87% سناب 78% تكتب
74% سبع ساعات يقضيها يعني على على الهاتف
او على الموبايل ايضا كيف شايف هذا
الموضوع كيف تقرا
ااا استاذ خالد
قضيه الجيل الجديد
واستخدام وسائل التواصل
من عملي بالجامعه ارى تغير سريع ايجابي في
قضيه الحصول على المعلومات لكن ايش
المشكله فيها ايضا هذا انه سبع ثمان ساعات
مع جهاز معنا عزله عن العالم الحقيقي وهذه
نشوف عندنا عند الاجيال بشكل همم حتى صارت
حتى عند الكبار
قضيه بس يعني انه قارب كمان تشوفه لا قضيه
الفراغ الروحي والجمال الذي الانسان
بالتفاعل الحقيقي مع البشر يعني الحديث
وجه الوجه تعبيرات الوجه همم مشاركه
الحكايات همم اذا اذا الاجيال الجديده
بتحصل المعلومه بسرعه وذكيه
لكن ماذا عن الابعاد غير المعرفيه غير
المعلومات
اذا سبع ساعات ثمان ساعات مع جهاز طيب متى
جاء متى الساعات اللي فيها تفاعل مع
الاخرين يعني اذا الواحد مثلا عمره
بالعشرينات سبع ساعات ثمان ساعات اذا جاء
عمره بالسبعين ما هي ذكريات العمر يعني
وين قضيه وقتك مع الاصدقاء او طلعت رحلات
الاشياء هذه لكن
ربما هناك اسئله كذلك اكثر اهميه منهم
هؤلاء كيف يفكرون همم كيف تشكلت ايضا
ثقافتهم كيف راح يكون دورهم مستقبلا في
التعامل مع الاحداث مع البلاد مع
الاحتياجات مع الاهداف مع الخطط مع
التنميه مع غيرها من الامور
لما لما اتكلم مع الشباب اليوم الان في
الجامعه يدرس في الجامعه مثلا عمره 20 19
21 22
اقرب في قيم العمل
لاجدادكم
للاباء اللي في عمري مننا احنا يعني يعني
الاجيال هذه ريستورنج استعاده قيام العمل
اللي يمكن انها انخفضت عند همم جيل الطفره
بالتالي من ناحيه قيم العمل نرى انه في
تحسن كبير
على الشركات الاعمال
همم يصنعون الماء في الكافيات في المشاريع
بالتاكيد هذا نشوف احنا بكثره وفي كل
مناطق المملكه
احصائيه البطاله
الرقم الادنى الاطلاق اربعه وشويه
ايجابيه سلبيه
يعني
السلبيه اللي انا خايف هي تجربه الحياه بس
القضيه انه سبع ساعات ثمان ساعات مع جهاز
تجربه جديده على البشر كلهم يعني ما نعرف
بعدين ايش يصير يعني مو الكاريكاتير اللي
مطلع هم كانت اول تمنع ولدها لا يروح
للشارع يلعب الان تسحب الولد بالقوه الى
الشارع هي القضيه
العمر التجارب بس في ناس تقول مثلا
نشوفهم مشغولين بالتوافق زي ما يقولوا انا
انقل ما يقوله
حريصين على متابعه اخبار
الحمقاء المغفلين وغيرهم انت شايفهم يعني
فعاليه فيها اي واحد من هؤلاء المشاهير
بتلقاهم بالالف موجودين همم رصيد ومن
الثقافه من العلم يكاد يكون صفر يعني
بالتالي هذا الخوف من انه هذا الجيل هو
الذي مواجهه مستقبل مواجهه التحديات هل
شايف انه الامر له خطوره ولا هذا مبالغ
يعني اكثر منك
ارى ان الجيل هذا من ناحيه المعلومات
المهارات احسن من يعني هو مره يقولون
باللغه الهيروغليفيه قبل 4000 سنه عند
الفراعنه لكن همم
مكتوب نص واحد 40 نكات ويقول انجيلها
يومين ما يحترم الكبار بس انا قبل 4000
سنه دائما يعني جزء من ثقافه البشر اكبر
لا ما عنده تقييم الجانبيه الافكار اللي
كانت موجوده الاسلام
طب ثقافيه بالمناسبه غير قضيه الحصول على
المعلومه غير قضيه المهاره غير قضيه
التحاق بالعمل اللي هي خارج التقرير
فكقييم اجمالي احنا نرى تقدم في الجير في
مهارات وفي معارفه في ما يصنع من واقعه
لكن عامل القلق اللي هي شرطته قبل قليل في
قضيه ايضا هذا اللي هي قضيه احترام
التعدد الثقافي همم يعني واحده من من اشعه
يعني واحده من عناوين المرحله ما بعد
يعني من الرؤيا والتعدد الثقافي اللي احنا
نفاخر في واللي نبرزه واللي نعتقد انه
عامل جذب ثقافتنا باعتبار انه
احد المناش حق صاحبها فبالتالي لازم الجيل
هذا ينشا على قضيه الاحترام والتعدد
الثقافي لانه باعتبار هذه احد يعني
مرتكزات هويه البلد والله فيها تفاصيل
كثيره
لكنها وضاعت
بنصبح على الجرح وربما حتى وجه التوصيات
للبرامج تحفيزيه وتمويليه ايضا لتوجيه
الناس اسابيع وفعاليات والتطبيقات والى
اخره شاكر مقدمه دكتور عبد السلام انا
استمتع دائما بحضورك استلام الوائل استاذ
علم الاجتماع المشارك في جامعه الملك سعود